je voulais dire c'est franchement il ya
un truc que je regarde en ce monde ouf
c'est un web série franchement et n est
les champs mais elle est embauchée par
tous elle c'est notre même dans le
désert on sait pas où elle a trouvé un
truc pour brancher un moment ils sont
hall désert tranquille comme un sale un
brushing tout fait sauf bas mais je te
jure t'amuser l'adorent commence à
savourer raconte nous un peu parce que
vivent les gens je sais que ça c'est un
truc de ouf tout ça cartonne et je moi
je suis comme un ouf de me retrouver
avec toi parce que là c'est un peu tu va
le mettre sa voiture et dans les marchés
matures bon sens oui je suis fan de rap
je suis fan de toi je n'ai ni charisme
ou bas par contre il faut reparler
parlez-moi plus vrai quoi vous êtes
passés au minibar bras pas du tout à la
halle à la boîte on cayla rouge
grenadine moi ça voilà je veux juste
faire ça parce que je sais qu'en plus
vous êtes and devices qui voit la passe
et des plus et moins huit mois par des
baies petite peluche grande bûche
importe aussi le message bisous c'est
que ces petites peluches petit but par
contre c'est plus grand que moi j'ai un
cadeau pour toi marois ça c'est vraiment
ça c'est ma plus je trouve ma chérie
elle est pas mal
franchement je sais que tu kiffes et
prennent armada
[Rires]
dans le droit ici vous quitteront qui
ont aidé à momo du maghreb
voilà où tu veux dire ok mais l'envoie
dans la websérie tu veux lui donner
babouche babouche pas j'adore ma voix
look est avec nous tout à l'heure je
fais un gros bisou de kif